the best-selling book tooth is with Mari
has inspired fans since its released 20
years ago the book details
soul-searching conversation between
sportswriter Mitch Albom and his dying
former college professor Morrie Schwartz
album has sold more than 15 million
copies of the book in 45 languages it
inspired an award-winning television
movie during the late Jack Lemmon and
Hank Azaria I just can't accept it I
don't want you to die I guess I flunked
the course and death ends a life not a
relationship author Mitch Avila is
joining says now welcome I have
forgotten the Jack Lemmon yeah he was
remarkable as really is his last film
basically what is it you've been asking
us a thousand times that so resonates
with people about this book I think most
people in their life have had a teacher
and so that's sort of their Maury I have
people open their wallets to me and
should take out a picture the
grandfather or some of them they say
this is my Maury you know and I think a
lot of people are lost like I was at
that age sort of saying I'm going a
thousand miles an hour and nothing seems
to be really meaningful and so they do
relate to my character or mortgage tax
but you know it's so interesting that
your book continues to thrive today as
Charlie said 15 million sold so far and
still selling but in the beginning
nobody paid any attention to you what's
right are you yeah actually we got
rejected a whole lot of places in this
city I still get haunted when I land
here you know they said it's you're a
sports writer it's depressing nobody
wants to read it because what was your
pitch what were you saying
I said I'm spending time with a dying
professor I'm really learning something
about life and I think it's important
and mainly I wanted to pay his medical
bills that was the whole reason for
writing it wasn't aimed to be a
best-seller or anything like that more
he had terrible debt for dying for two
years I had the idea to try to help pay
pay off by writing a book and had I not
been doing that I probably would have
given up there were so many people said
no to it but I kept pushing we found one
publisher a few weeks before he died and
they agreed to print it and they printed
20,000 copies and I thought I'd have
them in the trunk of my car for the rest
of my life but it turned out to be
something was it an instant bestseller
no no it wasn't slow
sort of bill people was in the old days
when people would read and hand it to
somebody hand it to somebody and then a
nice woman named Oprah Winfrey had me
come on for just five minutes at the end
of her show wasn't she'd make a book
pick or anything like that and that
changed it that began the big rise up
for it I think she loved that book I
remember that and a younger generation
is finding this book to I'm astounded
you know there's so many children that
are rights taught in schools around the
world in Japan and on Australia and I
always try to understand what how does
that relate to it I think because you
know like Maury said to me once I was an
only person to visit him and people were
going to try to cheer him up but then
he'd flip it on them and he'd ask them
about their divorce or their you know
then they'd be crying when they came out
they said I tried to cheer him up but he
was cheering me up and I said why do you
do that he said well why would I take
from people we want to just give me
sympathy giving makes me feel like I'm
living and I never forgot that that's
like a profound sentence and it also
rhymes and I think a lot of people
relate to that including young people
they understand that you know actually
if you give out more in a relationship
you get more and then all these years
later though you said once again it
happened to you adopt a little girl from
Haiti that years later you said it's
happened to me again I have to watch
somebody who I loved died well that was
a little girl yeah that was sort of
ironic barely 20 years almost to the
month that Maury that I reconnected with
Maury I have an orphanage in Haiti we
have 40 kids and one of our little girls
our name was chica developed a brain
tumor DIPG and I brought her up hoping
to just do a quick surgery and maybe get
her back and she ended up living with us
for two years and we went around the
world trying to save her and she passed
away four weeks ago today and you were
very kind of so I was supposed to do
your show right we are being burned but
you said you never felt so alive Mitch I
thought that was interesting well
because you know trying to teach her all
of a sudden trying to keep her alive you
realize it's precious the time that you
have left same thing with Maury and when
you realize Moore used to say keep a
little bird on your shoulder and ask it
every day is today the day I die and be
prepared for it to say one day yes it is
and when it says yes it is are you ready
and thinking like that like any day
could be the last day well that's what
my wife and I did with chica every day
and so you are intensely there and you
never really feel that alive you have
nine charities nonprofit charity in
Detroit yeah and the orphanage in Haiti
which I go to every month which was also
something that more had kind of taught
me you know you know you used to tease
me said what do you do for your
community I said you know charities I
said I write checks he said anybody can
write a check you have a voice you need
to share it that's why giving his living
Mitch legacy continues today thank you
really good to see you very sorry but
you look like thank you